you also have the role of China in Tech
with things like like Tick Tock and this
is something there if you look at the
tick tock that they use in China China
it's much different than what they're
trying to do in the United States with
China it's all China by the way it's
really funny hearing scientists talk
about technology does Santa's talk about
technology and foreign policy he sounds
genuinely clueless a very uh wholesome
patriotic uh in the United States
they're trying to inject as much garbage
into this as possible yeah isn't that
bizarre like this is not the biggest
issue but it is very strange very very
strange and Trump has a long history of
uh saying China in a really odd way
let's say China China
China China China China China China
China China
[Music]
[Applause]